what was the media feeding about you as
the are you saying defeatist the media's
feeding people that you are not Santa
Ana Komodo or what is the media feeding
that was part of it we had a lot of sort
of and we still get a lot of people
wanting to discredit what I'm doing so
this whole concept is whatever I do is
bad so citta she would never paint must
be health any help any of course
actually had patents and most of the
guys in Corps have patents and most of
the other people who hypocritically sit
there saying no can't be Craig because
have patents just I do it better so then
they sit there saying oh well you copied
this except you don't get a patent by
copying something and it's easy to make
the claim saying look this is just a
diffi holman process except if you write
a patent well which we do you have to
actually do this section called prior
art and in prior art you put all the
things that already exist and you
explain why you're different to them so
if you want to have a really good paint
you sit there a new document how things
really are now this is the existing
intellectual property these are the
existing inventions you know like when
you document other people's work in
other things and you basically put that
there and then you say but this is my
invention and what you actually have
patented is your invention not the
previous things but most people have
never filed a patent most people have
never done a thesis so when people sit
there and comment on these things it's
without knowledge without understanding
and it's very easy to sit there on
social media these days and this is a
part of the problem with things like
Twitter you can sit there and say oh
isn't that terrible but you don't care
about the truth
you don't care about what's real because
we have this whole culture now I'm not
doing something not actually going out
there and making a better world because
we don't need to anymore we can click
like I didn't actually have to go out
there and and help that person because I
liked the video of them suffering I said
that it was really terrible I saw and I
felt and I have mounted online and I
said I feel so bad and other people came
back to me and said we feel bad for you
that's our world now if we want to go
back to a biblical thing it's the Good
Samaritan except the Good Samaritan is
the one who isn't on social media
everyone else walking along they're the
ones who are on social media the
Pharisees who pass the guy and watch him
bleed but they get back and they tweet
about it and they say he was bleeding
but I'm really good because I made sure
I stayed pure if I got blood on my hands
I wouldn't be able to go to Temple on on
Sabbath and then the next group come
through and they sit there and they say
I'm so pure because obviously I'm with
other people and and we could have been
attacked and we want to live in fear
don't we we don't want to do something
because poor little me but what if it's
not just me what about these people I'm
with what about them any I know there's
any probably two attackers in this like
ten of us but but but what if some of us
get hurt so we will corn and that's what
our world is becoming we leave the
people there we sit there and we click
on people and we say isn't this great
because look what I've done I've helped
by clicking like you haven't and all
these people who think they have you're
scum
and if you don't like that get up you're
freaking out us and do something about
it
[Music]